Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
So recently people were visiting the set of
game of thrones season seven and spotted what
is going to be Daenerys is throne at Dragon
stuff she's had several different thrones
depending on where she's been throughout the
seasons that she had a throw next to Khal
Drogo when she was with the Dothraki then
is her army toured around she had makeshift
thrones.
Then she had the throne in the pyramid.
So the design of her thrones are usually taken
from whatever's there if they need to build
something new or put something together or
if one already exists there like the throne
inside the pyramid was already there.
They didn't have to build it for her is actually
pretty plain throne so that's why this is
so much more exciting because she's back at
Dragonstone, it's carved into the rock and
it looks like it might be in the great hall
all explained like the map of Dragon stoneware
all the rooms are the most people are familiar
with the room of the painted table that's
actually what the room is called in a Dragonstone
like and King's Landing.
You have the red keep maegor's holdfast the
room where the painted table is in Dragonstone
is just called the room of the painted table
you can see just like the TV shows done with
the iron throne.
They've really like strong things down because
the painted table is supposed to be about
50 feet long in the books.
And this looks like it's maybe half that in
there is like a special chair, it's in the
room of the painted table where Aegon would
be able to see the entire map, because normally
you'd have to like walk up and down the table to see
things really clearly but I'm guessing that
Daenerys' throne is going to be in the great
hall.
So just to go down the list is like the big
rooms and Dragonstone in the even cooler thing
is that there supposedly a lot of hidden chambers
that lead down to the heart of Dragonstone.
So maybe Daenerys will explore while she is
there.
It is pretty fair to say that we're gonna see
most of Dragonstone.
So just going on the list.
There's the stone drum which is like the central
keep he got the name just because weather
would beat it when they were really bad
storms.
It was sound like someone was banging a drum
so thus the stone drum but it's in here that
there supposedly hidden passageways the go
down to the heart of the mountain.
So anybody that's hoping to find a secret
clutch of Dragon eggs that would probably
be petrified by now it would probably be down
there.
Then next big room is the chamber the painted
table which I just explained, it's basically
the room just for the table for battle planning
purposes.
So then there's the great hall which looks
a little bit more like the throne room and
King's Landing.
I mean obviously is not that big but it's
a much bigger open room word be easier for
Daenerys to meet with her small counsel whatever
that's going to be think of it like winter
fell's great hall where Sansa and John are
holding court here with the people at the
end of season six is kind of like a bigger
much grander version of that so I'm guessing
that's where this throne is going to be within
there's a garden which is exactly what it
sounds like just a small Walton plays with
trees growing tall on every side with roses,
cranberries, so kind of a stark contrast from
the other places we've seen in Dragonstone.
So far, which seemed devoid of life.
But then there's the wind word which is kind
of like the tallest tower you can kind of
see it here.
There's the sea Dragon tower which is close
to the sea.
This is where the masers quarters are so Maester
Cressen if you remember him from the first
couple of seasons.
This is where his chambers were and then there's
the steps which is where all the idols of
the seven God's work before Stannis burned
them in the early seasons through all the
idols on the fire.
Maester Cressen was freaking out, crapping
his pants even Davos was skeptical which he
was right to be skeptical about Melisandre
but that's about all we've seen a Dragonstone.
So far, so I would expect because there's
so much stuff happening there in season seven
that they'll just be poking around there just
like we've seen different parts of the red
keep in King's Landing.
Throughout the seasons like a really big location
so they try to film it in different ways each
season because we have been a Dragonstone
a long time and we only seen a couple rooms
the just so many more places for them to explore,
so expect some really cool scenes inside Dragonstone
with the nearest just walking around trying
to get reacquainted with it because she was
born here but as a child she was secret it
across the so so she didn't live here for
that long.
So she probably doesn't have a really great
memory of it but I just like the idea of her
kind of like taking her place in her Targaryen
ancestral home on a throne is leading into
what's going to be having the final couple
seasons with the battle for the iron throne.
So even though there still some really big
seats in westeros like you have the sea
stone chair over in the iron Islands.
You have the great hall in winter fell but
in terms of like spectacular thrones.
You have Daenerys here in Dragonstone.
And Cersei obviously with the iron throne
but let me know what you guys think Dragonstone
is probably going to be one of the coolest
sets for next year.
The thing is is that it's kind of a challenge
for the production people in that there's
an extra level of ornate detail carvings,
stone carvings all over the place so there
are basilisk's cargo trees his demons griffins
hell hound manticore submitted towards we've
earned it all kinds of other minor creatures.
Just carved into the rock all over the place
so be interested to see how crazy they get
with that like you kind of see this Dragon
carved to the wall.
This is in the room of the painted table where
Stannis spends most of his time just staring
at the table itself but most of the design
is meant to be Dragon centric.
So you know wherever you see character standing
in frame just expect there to be Dragon stuff
in the background and really subtle ways just
kind of carved into the walls for the funny
thing is is that Dragonstone sounds like such
a Cool Place, Stannis always felt like Robert
thrusted upon him.
He's like I never asked for Dragonstone.
I never requested he always felt like it was
a slight like Robert was banishing him to
Dragonstone rather than giving him Dragonstone.
So just let me know what you want them to
do with those sets next year like how you
want them to use Dragonstone itself besides
the plot obviously there's gonna be a lot
of Dragon class there probably gonna try and
learn how to make valyrian steel again.
Although finding a lot of Dragon glass is
a lot easier valyrian steel is like a whole
level above that that's gonna require some
help from the sagittal exam well will say
congratulations to this week's giveaway winner
Jordi Lyons you and a $20 Amazon gift card
be sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your contact
details and there's a new round that starts
now there's a couple big things that are happening
in the next week or two so I might pose a
couple more bonus videos than I would normally
post for game of thrones so all you have to
do to enter the new giveaway is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video and just
a quick heads up to I just noticed in the
last couple of hours.
YouTube changed the mobile app so if you watch
my videos on your mobile phone subscriptions
are way down at the bottom now so it is closer
to your thumb.
I think that's why they put it down there
so they put all the garbage up here to the
top subscriptions is where you find the important
stuff like way down here at the bottom the
new walking dead new Marvel posting tomorrow
we just wait for that to post you can click
here for my reaction to the supposed spoilers
for season seven and you can click here to
learn all about Jon Snow maybe showing up
in daenerys' visions on the TV show the way
the TV shows changes things.
So thank you so much watching everybody high
five and I'll see you guys tonight!